eu resolvi que é uma palestra nova pra
vocês hoje primeira vez na sua palestra
na vida inclusive todos os desenhos são
originais tudo novidade
e quando o país natal na palavra viva
tem duas coisas que me vem à cabeça o
lado de brindar de celebrar mas eu
também penso muito como imperativo da
gente vê então eu trouxe pra vocês dez
dicas que são as dicas que eu mais uso
no meu dia a dia para conseguir curtir o
presente uma primeira dica o agora é
tanto a preparação quanto o show
isso é muito louco a gente não tem
ensaios na vida quando está no palco
o palco é a preparação para o futuro sem
dúvida mas também já é o seu presente
estão entendendo isso você consegue
perceber que cada dia a cada agora já é
o seu show de k2o agora só acontece uma
vez o agora como se fosse um momento que
está empurrando a cada momento só ele é
o agora
poxa se você se identificou por exemplo
hoje com algumas das iniciativas que as
pessoas trouxeram aqui agora é o momento
de lá se inscrever num stand up paddle
então fazer parte de alguma outra
iniciativa tem muita coisa legal que
você pode fazer
mas se você deixou agora passar agora
passou e algo também válido para coisas
tão simples como a vontade de dançar
valsa no meio do shopping porque tá
tocando uma música fofinha dançar valsa
no meio do shopping com música fofinho
não tem problema agora é agora
às vezes passa aquele momento que é tão
importante para você mostrar que tem a
ver com aquilo que se acabou de passar
dica 3
tudo que você tem é o agora
essa na verdade é uma das maiores etnias
parece tão simples mas é uma das noras
epifanias que eu tive na minha vida e
toda vez que eu tenho que colocar em
palavras eu não consigo colocar a
profundidade que eu quero conta a gente
pensa que a nossa vida é tudo que a
gente acumulou no passado e tudo que
estamos planejando para o futuro mas na
verdade
sua vida é o que você tem agora o que eu
tenho agora é o tex com vocês porque
vocês têm agora até domingo com outras
pessoas ótimas
a gente só tenham agora vou colocar um
exemplo simples aqui uma pessoa pode ter
tudo na vida tudo que é considerado pela
sociedade fantástico então uma família
incrível
uma pessoa que é um ótimo profissional é
também muito bem financeiramente mas
essa pessoa pode por exemplo está neste
momento numa viagem num carro que está
super perigoso por causa da chuva ele
vai ficar nessa situação por 45 horas e
situação e do outro lado pode ter uma
pessoa aqui que tal como a vida difícil
que talvez com uma doença com algumas
coisas difíceis na vida mas neste
momento está beijando a pessoa que ama
quem tem o melhor agora quem tem a
melhor vida o que você tem é o agora as
pessoas às vezes se prendem a tantas
outras coisas que são de antes ou que
virão depois
mas o que você tem de verdade é o agora
agora quando eu penso no que a gente tem
agora a gente definir qual é o
sentimento que a gente tem perante nosso
agora uma das liberdades mais lindas que
a gente tem como ser humano é a
liberdade de decidir qual o significado
você quer dar para as coisas e isso está
diretamente ligada também decidir o que
você está sentindo seu agora então
alguém pode passar por alguma situação
que acha que é um baita que é uma baita
injustiça que está errado ou pode ver
como um desafio pra se provar pra
crescer
na oportunidade ou é ou é realmente algo
ruim então você decide qual é o
significado que você dá pra aquilo que
está acontecendo pra você ou aquilo que
você foi atrás e em cima disso você
decide o sentimento que você tem aquele
agora é tudo que você tem
então na verdade a cada minuto o
significado que a gente dá para as
coisas definir o quanto a gente se sente
naquele momento outra coisa eu vejo
muita gente achando que o passado vai
definir o seu presente eo seu futuro
então se você teve um chefe
péssimos teve uma experiência péssima no
trabalho você tem pânico de tentar fazer
outra coisa porque vai que vai ser igual
ou então se você teve um namorado que
não foi uma pessoa legal tem medo de
entrar e não acredita mais no amor
o nosso passado não necessariamente vai
determinar o nosso presente nem o nosso
futuro
não é porque sempre deu errado que
alguma coisa vai continuar dando errado
nem por que sempre deu certo que vai
continuar dando certo para algumas das
suas ações no passado determinam como
você é e aqui você vai levar vai
continuar influenciando na sua vida toda
mas não é porque alguma vez não deu
certo você tem que desistir daquilo e
também não é porque sempre dá certo você
pode esquecer de seu melhor naquilo
a cada minuto você decide
como você pode fazer com que o seu
presente seja bem e preparar melhor o
futuro ea preparação e já o show
dica 6 às pessoas e hierarquizam os
momentos
então é assim a segunda de manhã é muito
pior do que sexta à noite
isso é um tapa na cara do seu tempo
porque toda tempo e toda a vida toda a
vida
as férias não são mais vida do que o
trabalho a gente tirar quiçá isso então
a gente precisa entender que a cada
momento você pode decidir que aquilo é a
vida e pode ser a melhor vida
dica 7 tudo pode ser fascinante de novo
a gente tirar quis assuntos também então
alguém levava alguma coisa que a gente
não conhece ou talvez não se interessa
tanto que a gente acha que aquilo não é
tão útil mas talvez daquilo pode sair
coisas incríveis
a gente teve aqui palestras poxa falamos
sobre como - pode ser fascinante vários
outros assuntos podem ser fascinante
também depende do do olhar que você
coloca naquilo
então tudo pode ser fascinante de cá
oito todo lugar
é hora de aprender a gente era que os
lugares também então principalmente
esperas e falou que espera daqui também
a gente acha que espera é tempo morto na
etapa extremamente já tempo morto numa
fila tempo morto esperamos aqui
às vezes daquele lugar pode ser algumas
oportunidades incríveis você pode
aprender algo incrível se pode conhecer
alguém incrível todo lugar
é hora para aprender e toda hora pra
aprender de k9 todo pouco conta
às vezes a gente pensa que precisa ser
um passo gigantesco para valer a pena
que tem que ser uma coisa eu tenho que
de zero pra sensi não valeu a pena meu
tempo
não adianta eu aprender são o primeiro
acorde eu preciso fazer saber cantar um
monte de coisa a aprender todo pouco
conta de quanto se pensa nas suas
habilidades comportamentais que pelo
menos pra mim foi uma das coisas que
mais me ajudaram a abrir portas na vida
então quando você pensa em desenvolver
liderança
quando você pensa em conseguir é
desenvolver a criatividade quando você
pensa em desenvolver visão iniciativa
determinação todo pouco conta é de pouco
em pouco que você faz uma grande
história em cima das habilidades
comportamentais dica 10 cada um de nós
tem uma maneira de ser
alguns de nós gosta de pegar um sábado e
ficar embaixo do edredom assistindo
netflix por 15 horas e tá tudo bem só
que a sociedade tenta mostrar pra gente
que não existem na natureza que tem que
ser aquilo que tem que fazer e aquilo
certo agora a melhor dica que eu
encontrei para conseguir curtir o
presente encontrar o que tem de melhor
na minha natureza aceitar e curtir
se você consegue pelo autoconhecimento
aumentar sua produtividade e também a
sua felicidade não tem como crítica não
tem como não curtir cada momento
agora o que eu queria pra vocês é um
contexto de quanto a gente consegue
fazer a cada tempo
então por exemplo um ano num ano a gente
pode por ter um filho a gente pode ter
um sabático que pode criar uma empresa
a gente pode melhorar nossa carreira no
mês a gente pode fazer um intercâmbio
que pode fazer projetos acontecerem no
meu caso quatro projetos que eu fiz
nesse ano em um mês um futuro da bell
que eu levei palestras em todas as
capitais do brasil criando oportunidades
é um curso - que dura um mês
criatividade conectado a um curso que
dura um mês e já fiz uma volta ao mundo
em menos de um mês
é muita coisa em um mês agora uma semana
vamos trazer mais por mais presente em
uma semana de muita coisa que a gente
pode fazer toda semana eu faço sete
diferentes episódios no podcast da bell
são sete temas diferentes e dá muito a
aprender muito numa semana existem
versões existem diversos programas
interessantes de uma semana é
recentemente eu passei uma semana na
nasa num programa de imersão se consegue
mudar sua cabeça em questão de dias é um
negócio muito louco
ali tem uma apostila lembra que quando
estava na época da escola semana pra mim
era o tempo que tentava terminar os
exercícios de uma apostila e num dia que
a gente consegue fazer um dia uma viagem
bate-volta dá pra fazer um dia uma
maratona de seriado que eu mencionei se
aquilo que você ama
dá pra fazer um dia dedicado um dia pra
sua família mostrar o quanto você ama
ele
eu nunca vou esquecer nesse cartaz
escrito feliz 15 anos brunão um dos dias
mais legais da minha vida quando eu
tinha 18 anos e me mudei para os estados
unidos eu fiz faculdade lá no haiti
e eu vejo a minha simples então foi a
primeira vez quando mudei pra lá que eu
não ia passar o aniversário com a minha
irmã tem uma irmã que eu amo muito a
gente é só se eu admiro ela é
incrivelmente e bem nos 15 anos dela
essa é a primeira vez que eu ia passar
longe dela aniversário eu não tinha e
estava morando em boston e não tinha
como ler trazê-la para boston e não
tinha como voltar porque estava muito
caro e eu falei já sei eu vou tentar
levar o boston ela fica difícil eu
comprei um livro com assim maiores
atrações de boston estava menos 27 graus
a sensação térmica naquele dia eu e meu
melhor amigo da época de faculdade a
gente visitou cada uma dessas 100
atrações no dia em cada uma das atrações
já estava com um banner feliz 15 anos
bruno o nome dela bruna a gente tira uma
foto em cada uma das atrações a gente
imprimiu essa foto substituiu as fotos
originais do livro com a nossa foto e
mandou esse livro pra ela e um dia dá
pra fazer muito em um dia e um dia pra
vocês estão cheios de idéias de negócios
dá pra fazer um campanhas do modelo de
negócio que pode viabilizar sua idéia dá
pra se aprofunda em qualquer proposta de
valor
ideia qual é o seu segmento de cliente
como você vai distribuir dá pra fazer
muita coisa tem dimensões de um dia
também eu coloquei pílula porque na
minha escola a gente chama de pílulas de
conhecimento e versões de um dia e numa
hora que a gente consegue fazer em uma
hora
assistir um filme um show ler um livro
fazer uma lista de tarefas do que a
gente vai fazer hoje houve um audiolivro
com um podcast talvez fazer um turno um
turno de empresas e coloquei ali é
cartas porque a última vez que eu venho
manaus e fiz o futuro da copag como são
feitos baralhos e talvez não tem muita
coisa legal que dá pra fazer o que dá
para fazer um minuto
agora está ficando interessante né que
dá fazer um minuto consegue fazer uma
ligação especial aquele cara engraçado
está tentando segurar na prancha quem
todo mundo tenta segurar na prancha sabe
que um minuto dura muito dura muito
você pode pular de paraquedas você pode
enviar uma mensagem importante para
alguém você pode fazer alguma anotação
importante você pode dar feedback no
projeto
eu tenho um projeto que eu chamo de
banca da ajuda que ajuda em um minuto a
gente dá feedback projetos e num segundo
que a gente pode fazer num segundo que
pode ter um insight uma ideia a gente
pode sorrir ea gente nunca sabe talvez
você olhar para o lado e sorri talvez
seja seu futuro marido seu futuro sócio
às vezes aquele sorriso vai ser útil pra
caramba você pode respirar fundo e
talvez por respirar fundo você deixa de
ser grosso ou deixa de atropelar alguma
coisa que poderia destruir alguma coisa
boa no futuro também
eu coloquei ali eu tocando uma campainha
porque em um segundo mudei minha vida
alguns anos atrás quando estava
prestando para a faculdade americana
a faculdade tem um processo diferente da
faculdade brasileira e eu não sabia e
quando eu fui descobrir tudo o que tinha
que fazer uma das coisas que tinham que
fazer entrevista com o ex aluno daquela
faculdade eu tinha perdido prazo que eu
fiz eu descobrir o endereço do cara e
num segundo toquei a campainha aquela
campainha tocada mudou minha vida não
tivesse tocado a campainha e ele tivesse
atendido e ele não
esse feito na entrevista comigo eu não
teria feito várias das coisas que eu fiz
depois outra coisa
às vezes uma decisão também é feita no
segundo eu comecei um movimento
recentemente sobre você descobrir o seu
mais profundo ser que eu estou chamando
de seu código seu manual de instruções e
abriu mais relevante disso o movimento
que chama de meu código aberto é um
aplicativo tem um livro meu código
aberto
agora nessa intenção de buscar sua
melhor versão no seu código aberto uma
coisa você entender o que pode ser sua
melhor versão outra coisa é tomar
decisões para que você chegue mais
próxima daquela versão
então eu comecei um caderninho da
transformação hoje caderninho nota
coisas em caderninhos e okada além da
transformação é uma decisão por dia
simples mas uma decisão importante para
te deixar chegar mais perto da sua
melhor versão não segundo você também
consegue fazer uma decisão e agora eu
queria usar meus últimos dois segundos
aqui pra vocês participarem comigo em
coisas que a gente consegue fazer um
segundo
primeiro em um segundo agente consegue
abraçar forte a pessoa do lado e falar
que foi legal tela com a gente nesse
evento
vamos fazer isso em um segundo a gente
consegue também virá para o outro lado e
compartilhar algum insight muito legal
de alguma coisa que a gente aprendeu
aqui e espero que tem mais segundo mas é
uma compartilham um insight muito legal
uma sacada legal
luciana e o último segundo
o último segundo da minha palestra eu
queria usar para agradecer e um segundo
agente consegue também bater fortes
palmas pra todo mundo que fez desse
evento e tem mais ainda nesse evento com
sucesso
parabéns a toda equipe